Imagine you have two beakers filled with equal amounts of water
and they are both connected
to each other by a pipe at the bottom
If you observe the two beakers for a few seconds
Do you think the water will flow from one beaker to another?
No. You will see that the water in
both beakers is as is and there is no
flow from any beaker to the other.
Now let me give you a task.
Without changing the amount of water in any of the beakers,
Can you make water flow from Beaker 2 to Beaker 1?
Understand my question again. You need to make
water flow from Beaker 2 to Beaker 1
but you're not allowed to change the amount of water
in any of the beakers. So you can't add
or remove the water from any beaker.
How will you do it?
It's easy! One of the things you could do
is raise the height at which the second beaker is kept.
Once it's raised at a height, the water will flow
from beaker 2 to beaker 1.
What exactly happened here? What was
the factor that made water flow?
In simple terms the factor was height
Yes you can talk about gravity or pressure difference.
But in layman terms it is the height difference
that causes the water to flow from the second beaker to the first.
In an exactly similar way, for electricity to flow
there has to be some factor.
We'll come to that factor soon. Don't worry.
So if we have a copper wire do you think
Electricity will flow through it?